Sie eher bei sieben?
Bis zu zwei Tagen, ca. sieben.
Ja.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, okay.
Und Frau Weller,
wenn ich richtig verstanden habe,
Sie haben sehr, sehr
starke Schmerzen.
Möchten Sie noch
eine Schmerzmittel? Kann ich Ihnen geben?
Also ich habe Schmerzmittel
ausprobiert. Ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen.
Ja, das habe ich gestern genommen.
Zwei Tabletten.
Aber das hat nicht viel
geholfen.
Im Augenblick kann ich es aushalten,
wenn es nicht allzu lange dauert jetzt,
die Untersuchung.
Okay, okay, okay.
Und wie viele Miteln haben Sie
Ibuprofen eingenommen?
Ich glaube, da stand 400 drauf.
Da habe ich zwei genommen, gleichzeitig.
Gleich mal.
Okay, insgesamt
800 Miteln.
Aber gestern Abend.
Aber es hat nicht viel geholfen.
War kein guter Erfolg.
Okay.
Dann haben Sie noch
Schwellungen.
Und dann
Ich würde gerne wissen,
strahlen die Schmerzen
irgendwo hinaus,
zum Beispiel in den
Unterschenkel?
Nein, nein, nein.
Sie sind nur Oberschenkel.
Nur Unterschenkel.
Gibt es einen bestimmten
Auslöser für die Schmerzen
oder Schwellungen?
Habe ich keine Erklärung für.
Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich kenne keinen Grund.
In der Lasterzeit haben Sie
ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Alle sind
plötzlich aufgetreten.
Ja, aber langsam.
Langsam.
Sie haben sich langsam entwickelt.
Langsam entwickelt.
Begrünt.
Und, ja.
Gibt es, haben Sie noch
andere Beschwerden?
Die Schmerzen eben,
dass das so leicht geschwollen ist.
Und die Haut ist so ein bisschen
wärmer da an der Stelle.
Das ist etwas warm. Aber sonst
habe ich keine anderen Beschwerden.
Gibt es noch eine
Fertveränderung oder?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nur ein bisschen
Wärme.
Gibt es noch
keine
Rotausschlag oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Und dann.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber
ich habe nicht das Gefühl.
Schwissen nach Schweiß,
Kalschweiß oder sowas?
Nein.
Okay.
Und dann
Übelkeit oder Aggression?
In der letzten Zeit.
Also mir ist so etwas
übel jetzt, aber erst seit zwei
Tagen, seitdem die Schmerzen so stark
sind. Aber
übel ist mir etwas, aber ich habe nicht
erbrochen.
Okay, ohne Erbrochen.
Vielen Dank.
Und haben Sie noch
Herzrasen, Herzklopfen,
Atemnot oder Engelgefühl?
Nein, nein. Herzrasen, Herzklopfen
habe ich nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch
keine Probleme?
Zum Beispiel beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, Wasserlassen.
Ich muss in der Nacht
ein bis zwei Mal auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber das schon seit einigen Jahren.
Hängt davon ab, wie viel ich abends trinke.
Wie viel Wasser ich trinke oder
Tee. Toilette
ist in Ordnung. Stuhlgang habe ich jeden
Tag. Okay, kein Problem.
Beim Wasserlassen
oder Stuhlgang.
Haben Sie noch eine Schlafstörung?
Ja, in den letzten Tagen
schon durch die Schmerzen.
Da konnte ich schlecht schlafen.
Sonst kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen.
Schmerzbedingte.
Ich habe das
notiert und
habe es nicht so gut gemacht.
Gibt es noch etwas
gleichzeitig
Beschwerden?
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefallen?
Nein.
Gleichzeitig Beschwerden,
gleichzeitig habe ich nicht. Nein.
Zum Beispiel fühlen Sie sich
müde,
erschöpft oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich jetzt
ein bisschen erschöpft heute, weil eben
ich habe Schmerzen. Deswegen habe ich nicht gut
geschlafen und da bin ich jetzt
etwas erschöpft.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Und gibt es
Appetit?
War eigentlich ganz gut.
Der Appetit. Jetzt mit den starken Schmerzen
war der Appetit nicht so gut.
Da habe ich nicht so viel gegessen.
Ich habe versucht, es zu trinken.
Okay.
In der letzten Zeit
haben wir noch eine
Gewichtveränderung.
Haben Sie schon
bemerkt? Nein.
Mein Gewicht habe ich eigentlich gehalten.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch
irgendwelche kränische
Erkrankungen?
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
Seit einigen Jahren habe ich eine
chronische Bronchitis.
Und war da
auch und bin da auch in Kontrolle beim
Lungenarzt.
Und ich nehme da auch etwas ein,
ein Spray. Aber ich war jetzt, das hat
so einen schwierigen Namen.
Ich habe das vergessen.
Mein Mann bringt das aber
später nach in die Ambulanz.
Der bringt die Medikamente alle mit.
Aber ich weiß diesen Namen
des Sprays nicht. Da muss ich zweimal
am Tag nehmen.
Okay. Haben Sie noch
einen Medikamentplan dabei?
Nein, habe ich leider nicht.
Bringt mein Mann alles mit.
Kein Problem. Ich werde
mit Ihrem Hausarzt in Färbenung
setzen.
Kein Problem.
Ich hatte als Kind
musste ich eine
Spreizhose tragen.
Als kleines Kind, da hatte ich Probleme
mit der rechten Hüfte.
Aber das hat sich dann wieder gegeben.
Und danach habe ich da keine Beschwerden
mehr gehabt.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, wurde ich.
Ich wurde vor 30 Jahren operiert.
Da wurde
meine Tochter geboren. Mit
Kaiserschnitt.
Das war vor 30 Jahren.
Und vor 10 Jahren
wurde ich operiert
an der Schilddrüse.
Weil ich hatte eine
vergrößerte Schilddrüse und auch
zwei Knoten.
Im rechten Schilddrüsenlappen.
Und da wurde die Schilddrüse weitgehend
entfernt.
Und da muss ich dann jetzt auch immer
eine Tablette nehmen.
Okay.
Ich kenne dich. Das ist
L-Tyroxin.
Kenosin.
Da steht
hinter 50.
Da nehm ich
eine morgens.
Ja.
Dann wurde ich vor
anderthalb Jahren.
Eineinhalb Jahre wurde
bei mir Bronchalkrebs
festgestellt.
Und da wurde ich operiert.
Das war auf der rechten Seite.
Da wurden Teile
von meiner Lunge entfernt.
Rechte Seite.
Rechte Seite. Teile von meiner Lunge
wurden entfernt. Und anschließend
wurde es noch bestrahlt.
Strahlungsbehandlung nach der
Operation.
Und ich bin da aber auch immer in Kontrolle.
Und zuletzt
war ich vor vier Monaten bei der
Kontrolle. Und da war so weit
alles in Ordnung.
Alles gut. Aktuell
haben Sie kein Problem.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt,
letzte Kontrolle war vor
drei Monaten. Vier Monate. Vor
vier. Vier, vier Monate.
Okay.
Und das war
alles in Ordnung.
Und?
Haben Sie noch Husten?
Manchmal habe ich schon Husten durch
die chronische Bronchitis.
Chronische Bronchitis.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
aber ich würde gerne wieder
fragen,
wann war letzte Kontrolle
beim Lungenarzt?
Ja, da war ich jetzt ja auch beim Lungenarzt
wegen dem Krebs.
Auch da war ich beim Lungenarzt vor
vier Monaten. Und der
hat aber auch ausführlich Blut
abgenommen und getestet.
Aber er sagte, so weit
ist das jetzt erstmal gut.
Ich muss aber auch
noch zum Onkologen gehen.
Da muss ich
auch noch hin. Aber das ist erst, die
Kontrolle ist erst in, ich glaube,
im Mai.
Also jetzt in sechs Wochen, acht Wochen.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Haben Sie chronische Bronchitis
und
haben Sie noch
Bronchial Krebs.
Wegen
dieser Beschwerden haben Sie schon
operiert worden.
Und?
Als Medikamentus
nehmen Sie außer Ertroxin
andere Medikamente?
Ja, einmal dies für die Bronchitis,
Spray. Aber ich kann Ihnen
den nicht sagen, den Spray. Das wird geklärt.
Mein Mann bringt das Präparat.
Wegen
Bronchitis
und Medikament
nur Ertroxin und
wegen
Bronchitis ein Spray.
Okay. Das ist alles.
Frau Weller,
haben Sie noch
Allergien gegen etwas?
Nein, Allergien habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Unverträglichkeit?
Frau Weller, rauchen Sie?
Nicht mehr.
Ich habe geraucht,
bis zur Diagnose
Bronchial Krebs. Also bis vor
anderthalb Jahren habe ich geraucht.
Lange, 30 Jahre lang
und jeden Tag
eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
30 Jahre lang?
Ja.
Ich habe schon geraucht
unter anderthalb Jahren.
Ja, vor anderthalb Jahren
bekam ich ja die Diagnose
Lungenkrebs, Bronchial Krebs.
Und da habe ich das Rauchen aufgehört.
Okay, super. Super.
Das ist eine
sehr schöne Entscheidung.
Drinken Sie
Alkohol?
Ja, wenig.
Ein bis zwei Glas
Wein pro Woche.
Glas Wein pro Woche.
Entschuldigung Sie,
bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen
nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen
konsumiert?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ich möchte wieder fragen,
wann war
Ihre Strahlentherapie?
Die war direkt
nach der Operation.
Nach der Operation. Also einige
Wochen später, ich weiß nicht,
vier Wochen später, vier Wochen später
war eine Bestrahlungsserie.
Aber das waren einige
Bestrahlungen. Ich habe es nicht mehr genau im Kopf,
aber es waren, glaube ich, mindestens 20.
Wie lange dauerte
die Strahlentherapie?
Das waren einige Wochen.
Nur einige Wochen.
Nach der Operation.
Kennen Sie
die Gewebeprobeergebnisse?
Was war die Pathologie
befunden?
Weiß ich nicht. Man hat mir nur gesagt,
das ist Krebs. Das ist Lungenkrebs.
Bronchalkrebs.
Okay, kein Problem.
Ich werde
mit Ihrem Hausarzt in Vergnügung
setzen. Dann nehme
alle Ergebnisse.
Und
Frau Welle
haben Sie noch
in Ihrer Familie
irgendwelche krankes Erkrankungen?
Ja.
Mein Vater hatte
Lungenkrebs. Und da ist er auch dran
gestorben. Da war er 68
Jahre alt. Im Alter von 68
Jahren ist er an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Okay.
Ist mir alt.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Die Mutter, die ist jetzt 89
Jahre alt. Die lebt.
Die hat Alterszucker.
Und sie hat
schwere Arthrose an der rechten
Hüfte.
Schwere Arthrose.
Und dann habe ich noch einen
Bruder.
Der ist 60 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen
Blutdruck.
Und er hat
hohe Harnsäure und
auch zweimal Gichtanfall schon gehabt.
Ihr Bruder?
Gicht.
Harnsäure. Die ist
hoch. Harnsäure. Und hat zweimal
Gichte gehabt. Und er hat starke
Schuppenflechte.
Starke Schuppenflechte.
Schuppenflechte. Beide.
Diese Patientin,
Entschuldigung, ich habe
nicht genau verstanden.
60 Jahre alt. Ihre Bruder?
Ja, 60 Jahre.
Er ist ein Jahr jünger als ich.
Ihre Mutter?
87, 89.
Ja, 89. Okay.
Hab das was
notiert. Vielen Dank
für die Information. Und
Ihre
Bruder hat
Gichtanfälle
und Schuppenflechte.
Okay.
Frau
Wöller, sind Sie
verheiratet?
Ja, bin verheiratet
und wohne
mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Die Tochter lebt nicht mehr bei uns.
Die ist ja schon 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt. Eine Tochter.
Okay.
Was machen Sie? Birfli?
Ich bin Polizistin.
Ja. Und war
bis zu der Operation
an der Lunge war ich im
Außendienst und jetzt seit der
Operation arbeite ich im
Innendienst. Das ist weniger
stressig.
Ja, natürlich. Deswegen
in diesem Moment.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Und
Frau Wöller,
möchten Sie noch etwas
hinzufügen?
Nein, das ist ja eigentlich
alles gesagt worden.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie noch
irgendwelche
Rotausflag, zum Beispiel
im Gesicht oder
andere Regionen?
Nein. Nein, gar nicht.
Einige welche werden, haben Sie
nicht bemerkt. Und
haben Sie schon gesagt,
haben Sie keine Atemnot
oder... Nein, habe ich nicht.
Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Sie haben keine
Bluthochdruck oder...
Habe ich nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Frau Wöller,
ich bin nun mit
meinen Fragen fertig.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht zur Zeit.
Danke. Ja, gut.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit,
die Patientensprache
zu übersetzen in
Fachbegriffe, wenn es geht.
Denken Sie an den Begriff wie Übelkeit
oder so etwas.
Und die Kollegen, die
zugeschaut, zugehört haben,
herzlich willkommen.
Gibt es noch Ergänzungsfragen?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, bitte.
Träten die
meistens Tagsüber
oder Nacht auf?
Die sind immer.
Die sind immer. Und besonders seit zwei Tagen,
bisher konnte ich ja noch
mich bewegen in der Wohnung.
Zur Toilette gehen
und so. Aber das kann ich seit zwei Tagen
nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht auf dem Bein
stehen. Ich kann mich, ich kann nicht
gehen. Sie können nicht gehen.
Danke schön.
Frau Wehler,
ich möchte noch eine Frage
stellen.
Haben Sie noch Sport
treiben?
Sport treibe ich nicht, nein.
Früher habe ich das mal gemacht,
aber das ist schon lange her.
Gibt es
sonst noch
Fragen?
Haben Sie eine Säcke
bis bemerkt?
Zerken bis habe ich
nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nein.
Kann ich nicht sagen, habe ich nicht
bemerkt.
Haben Sie in den Beinen gestoßen?
Ja, das ist eine
durchaus wichtige Frage.
Ich würde gefragt haben,
an Ihrer Stelle, haben Sie in letzter Zeit
zum Beispiel einen Unfall gehabt
oder einen Sturz?
Ein Unfall ereignix. Kann ja mal
sein, dass ein Unfall gestürzt ist,
vor einigen Tagen sogar und jetzt Schmerzen hat.
Nein, ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass ich mich irgendwie verletzt gestoßen
habe oder dass ich einen Unfall hatte.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie hoffene Wunde in
der betroffenen Bein?
Nein, offene Wunde habe ich
nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nein. Das ist nur etwas
geschwollen, da an der Hauptschmerz
Stelle, da am Oberschenkel,
oberhalb des Knies.
Und es ist etwas
wärmer, etwas,
aber nicht viel.
Wie
kommen Sie in den
Krankenhaus? Wie kamen Sie in den
Krankenhaus?
Ein Nachbar hat mich gefahren, der hat einen
Rollstuhl gehabt.
Und da hat er mich in den Rollstuhl gesetzt
und hat mich dann hierhin gefahren,
mit dem Auto und dann hinten in die
Krankenhäuser einfahrt.
Ich bin nicht mit dem Krankenwagen gekommen.
Mein Nachbar, der ist stark.
Es wäre noch eine Frage vielleicht zu
stellen zum Schmerz.
Fragen Sie den Schmerzcharakter.
Wie ist
der Schmerz? Ist der Schmerz
stechend, ist er
klopfend? Nein, der Schmerz
ist eher dumpf, dumpf
und bohrend.
Das ist der Schmerzcharakter.
Dumpf und bohrend.
Ich konnte nicht genau
folgen. Die Schmerzintensität
wurde gefragt, oder nicht?
Ja, die Schmerzintensität war im Anfang
so 3 bis 4.
Und jetzt seit zwei Tagen ist sie fast
7.
Haben Sie etwas gegen
den Schmerz
eingenommen? Ja, das
hat der Kollege auch schon gefragt. Ich habe
Ibuprofen genommen.
400,
zwei Tabletten auf einmal
gestern. Aber es
hat keine Wirkung gezeigt.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Wir können ja den Kollegen
mal noch ein, zwei Minuten
in Ruhe
sich vorbereiten lassen, so gut das geht.
Und dann komme ich sofort
wieder.
Ich habe
eine neue Patientin
aufgenommen. Es geht um
Marion Wehler,
61 Jahre alt
und geboren
17.9.1964
1,64 Meter groß
und 65 Kilo
wiegt.
Frau Marion Wehler
stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit
drei Tagen
rechtzeitiger
Oberschenkelschmerzen.
Kurz
vor
rechter Knie
und seit drei Tagen
hat sie auch
dicke und geschwollene
Beine.
Darf ich Sie mal kurz unterbrechen?
Ja. Die Schmerzen sind erst
seit drei Tagen?
Geschwollen
seit drei Tagen. Ja, und die Schmerzen,
seit wann sind die Schmerzen?
Entschuldigung.
Seit drei Tagen
hatte sie
drei Wochen.
Drei Wochen.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, seit drei Wochen habe
ich Schmerzen am Oberschenkel.
Am Oberschenkel.
Und zwar am unteren
Oberschenkel, also oberhalb des Knie.
Ja.
Das ist seit drei Wochen. Aber jetzt
seit zwei Tagen haben die
Schmerzen zugenommen.
Sie sind ganz stark geworden.
Ja.
Und dass sie jetzt sich nicht mehr gut
bewegen kann.
Und die
Schwellung bezieht sich nur
auf den Schmerz
puncto maximum.
Also am Oberschenkel
liegt das ganze Bein.
Es ist nur eine bestimmte Schwellung.
In einem bestimmten Bereich.
So groß wie vielleicht wie eine Handfläche oder so.
Ja.
Schmerzen schützen nicht
die Schmerzen.
Ja.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen
schrallen nicht
aus.
Beschreiben Sie nochmal den Schmerz.
Wo der Schmerz ist.
In welchem Körperteil.
Und möglichst mit dem medizinischen
Begriff. Sie haben gesagt Oberschenkel.
Oberschenkel.
Femur.
Femur. Ja genau.
Nennen Sie dann ruhig Femur.
Ja.
Wenn die Patientin sagt
ich habe Schmerzen im rechten
Femur. Und zwar
im unteren Bereich. Dann heißt das eher
im distalen Femur.
Distal.
Patientin berichtet über Schmerzen
im distalen Femur.
Oder man kann auch sagen
Suprapatellar.
Ja.
Suprapatellar. Weil es direkt oberhalb
der Kliescheibe ist.
Suprapatellar. Dann hat man den Ort
lokalisiert.
Und verbunden mit einer
lokalen Schwellung.
Und leichten.
Kann man ruhig sagen Überwärmung.
Aber Femur sollten Sie
ruhig sagen. Distaler Femur.
Distaler Femur.
Gut.
Schmerzintensität liegt
vor zwei Tagen
4 und 5.
Und
die letzten zwei Tage
7 und 5.
Ja. Okay.
Und deswegen
der Patient hat
zwei Tabletten
überprofen.
400 mg Eier eingenommen.
Aber das
hat nicht geholfen.
Okay. Gut.
Das ist jetzt der Schmerz.
Wie wird der Schmerz beschrieben?
Wie der Schmerz ist?
Schneidend? Bohrend?
Dechend?
Der Patient hat berichtet,
dass der Schmerz
dunft und bohrend ist.
Okay. Gut. Dann haben wir das.
Wir haben einen starken Schmerz.
VHS 7.
Dumpf und bohrend.
Mit lokaler Schwellung
und Überwärmung.
Der Schmerz ist Distaler Femur.
Dann haben wir die Lokalisation.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Und
hat die Patientin so etwas schon einmal gehabt?
Der Patient
hat bei der
Vorerkrankung
ein chronisches
Hüsten und Vorhund.
Hat die Patientin diesen Schmerz?
Ist das zum ersten Mal
dieser Schmerz? Oder hat sie
diesen Schmerz früher schon einmal gehabt?
Voriges Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren?
Ja, früher schon
unsere Patientin
ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Aber in der letzten Zeit
der Schmerz
schlimmer geworden.
Gut.
Hat die Patientin
einen Unfall gehabt?
Keinen.
So etwas
hat sie nicht.
Sagen Sie ruhig
ein Unfallereignis liegt
wohl nicht vor.
Das ist wichtig, weil das wird
garantiert gefragt werden in der Prüfung.
Von einem Oberarzt,
der fragt garantiert, liegt ein Unfall
vor oder ein Sturzereignis?
Das
möglichst immer fragen.
Gut.
Das haben wir jetzt.
Hat die Patientin chronische Erkrankungen?
Sie wollten gerade damit beginnen.
Ja, die Patientin
erwähnte
sie
sie hatte
eine chronische
Bronschitis
aber unter Kontrolle.
Und seit
anderthalb Jahren
bei ihr
eine Bronchiakrebsdiagnostisiiert.
Bronchiakrebs, ja?
Bronchialkarzinom?
Bronchialkarzinom
vor anderthalb Jahren.
Und wie wurde das behandelt?
Und bei ihr
wurde eine
Torquetomie und
ja, partial
Lobetomie.
Ja, man weiß die, wir wissen es
noch nicht genau, weil die Patientin,
wir haben ja noch keinen Arztbrief
oder wir wissen nicht genau, was gemacht wurde.
Sagen Sie ruhig, die Patientin
wurde operiert.
Das ist weit gefasst.
Und was wurde noch gemacht?
Nach der Operation
bei ihr
Radiotherapie durchgeführt.
Eine Radiazio oder Radiotherapie
durchgeführt, ja.
Gut, ist die Patientin
in onkologischer und
pneumologischer Kontrolle?
Ja,
letzte Kontrolle war vor
vier Monaten.
Nächste Kontrolle wird
im Mai.
Diese chronische Bronchitis,
wissen Sie, wie lange
die ist?
Ist die erst aktuell oder
ist die schon langjährig?
Ja,
bei der letzte Kontrolle
den Arzt
hat
unser Patient ein Medikament
gegeben, aber
die Name
oder die Dosis
leider nicht klar.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es ist
ein inhalatives,
ein Präparat zur Inhalation.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, ich nehme
das zweimal am Tag, aber wir
wissen noch nicht genau, um was
es sich handelt. Das wird geklärt.
Sagen Sie das ruhig, das wird geklärt.
Und bei der chronischen
Bronchitis, in diesem Fall, die
langjährig besteht, gehen wir wahrscheinlich
aus von einer COPD.
Sagen wir jetzt mal, wir
kommen ja nachher noch dahinter, was
vielleicht der Sache zugrunde liegt.
Wir kommen nachher auf den Nikotinkonsum
und auf die Sachen.
Was hat die Patientin
noch an chronischen Erkrankungen
oder an Medikamenteneinnahme
Richtung beider chronischen Erkrankungen?
Vor zehn Jahren
bei ihr einen
Troidectome
zurückgeführt wurde.
Deswegen...
Warum?
Das hat
zwei
Knoten
existiert,
aber die Diagnose
leider nicht bekannt.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, ich hatte eine
vergrößerte Schilddrücke.
Sie berichtet eine Schilddrücke.
Vergrößert.
Da unten steht es.
Romanodosa. Perfekt.
Erinnern Sie sich
an die richtigen Begriffe.
Setzen Sie sie nur ein.
Sie sollten sie benutzen.
Stroma nodosa.
Das war wohl die Diagnose.
Deswegen fand wohl eine subtotale
Tyroidectomie statt.
Keine komplette, sondern subtotal.
Deswegen nimmt die Patientin
auch ein Medikament?
Entroxin.
Sie wässte 50
Mikrogramm
regelmäßig.
Okay.
Einmal pro Tag wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es sonst noch was?
Hat die Patientin noch was berichtet?
Vor 30
Jahren war er
ein
Sexio cesare.
Kann man ruhig sagen,
Sexio cesare
vor 30 Jahren.
Gut.
Die Patientin hatte noch was erwähnt.
Als Kleinkind musste sie eine
sogenannte Spreizhose tragen.
Ja, bei ihm
eine
Dislocation
von der
Rechte Hüfte diagnostiziert.
Und die ähnliche
Beschwerden hatte ihre
Mutter.
Auf die Familienanamnese
kommen wir gleich noch.
Okay.
Prima.
Jetzt haben wir die chronischen Erkrankungen.
Eine langjährige chronische
Bronchitis, wahrscheinlich COPD.
Vor 18 Monaten
Diagnose eines
Bronchialkartinoms mit
OP und Radiatio.
Vor 10
Jahren war eine
Tyroidectomie, subtotal
wegen Stromanudosa.
Und dann eine Sexio.
Gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten
in der Familienanamnese?
Ja, bei der Familienanamnese
ergab
einen
Bronchialkartinom
bei der Vater.
Und lebt der Vater
noch?
Leider wegen
Bronchialkartinom
verstorben.
Und in welchem Alter?
64.
68 Jahre.
Das Alter von 68 Jahren
ist er an einem Bronchialkartinom
oder Lungenkarzinom verstorben.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Sie ist
89 Jahre alt.
Sie
hatte alte Zucker
und eine Arthrose
und rechte Hüfte.
Ja, sagen Sie mal den Fachbegriff.
Ja,
Gonarthrose.
Nein, das ist Kniearthrose.
Gonarthrose ist Knie. Und die Hüfte?
Hüfte Coxe.
Coxe-Athrose.
Coxe-Athrose
ist die Hüftarthrose
der Hüfte.
Also der Arthrose der rechten Hüfte.
Ich habe gesagt Alterszucker.
Der Begriff Alterszucker medizinisch.
Ja, Gebetsmedizine.
Typ 2.
Okay. Gibt es
Geschwister?
Sie hat
einen Geschwister,
einen Bruder.
Er hatte einen
Gifterkrankung.
Giftauffall.
Bei ihm
wurde die Admonxisiert.
Schuppenflechte.
Kennen Sie den Begriff Schuppenflechte?
Systemic Lepus
Erithematosus.
Wir sagen eigentlich Psoriasis.
Psoriasis.
Psoriasis, das ist die Schuppenflechte.
Schuppenflechte.
Und der Gichtanfall.
Kann Sie da einen Begriff für Gichtanfall?
Gut.
Gutkrankheit.
Wir sagen
Arthritis Urica.
Weil zugrunde liegt
eine erhöhte Harnsäure.
Und das ist die Hyperurikämie.
Hyperurikämie.
Und der Bruder hat aber noch eine
chronische Erkrankung.
Können Sie sich erinnern?
Ja, ich habe das nur zwei
bekannte Krankheiten.
Er hat noch
einen Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Okay, ich habe das nie.
Aber den Begriff kennen Sie,
von Bluthochdruck.
Hypertonie, Arthelie.
Arthelie, Hypertonie.
Ich versuche einfach nur nochmal, dass Sie sich
in das medizinische...
Weil wir machen jetzt ja eine
fachmedizinisches Training.
Gut.
Wir haben also eine auffällige
Familienanamnese.
Insofern, dass der Vater mit 68
Jahren an einem Bronchialkarzinom oder
Arthelie gebraucht ist.
Die Mutter mit ihrer
Koksathrose und
mit ihrem Diabetes.
Der Bruder mit Arthritis
Ulrica und
Psoriasis.
Gibt es sonstige Risikofaktoren
bei der Patientin?
Risikofaktoren...
vor dem OP.
In ca. 30 Jahren
die Patienten
ein Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag und treibt nicht Sport.
Okay, wie würden Sie sagen, wenn jemand 30 Jahre lang raucht und eine Schachtel pro Tag raucht?
Ja, eine Schachtel.
Ja, kennt Sie da so einen Begriff? Wir sagen 30 Packages.
Packages, ja.
Ja, 30 Packages.
30 Packages.
Ich würde ruhig sagen, die Patientin hat bis zu 30 Packages.